[Música]
ustedes y yo tenemos algo en común ambos
tenemos todo lo que necesitamos para
innovar
hace unos años gané una beca para ir a
estudiar el exterior
hice un posgrado orientado en innovación
específicamente
actualmente estoy trabajando como
gerente de innovación digital
en una empresa multinacional que
invierte 9 mil millones de dólares al
año en innovación
cuando uno le pregunta a mi madre que
hago ella piensa que estoy todo el día
programando
mis amigos piensan que me la paso
conectando tecnología servidores cosas
complejas
mi novia piensa que me la paso todos los
días jugando a los jueguitos
electrónicos
pero la realidad es que me la paso de
reunión en reunión tratando de convencer
a gente de que tienen que hacer las
cosas de una u otra manera me quedé
pensando durante un tiempo que tomo
decisiones sobre inversiones en
tecnología y proyectos digitales y era
un analfabeto digital
entonces para remediarlo
me anoté en un congreso de programadores
era el único que no entendía
absolutamente nada de lo que estaban
hablando las 400 personas que estaban
ahí luego tuve la oportunidad de
participar en varios hackathon es que si
saben lo que es básicamente gente que no
se conoce se junta para tratar de
resolver un problema en periodos muy
cortos de tiempo generalmente un fin de
semana ya no tiene un curso de
programación finalmente dije no puedo no
saber programar así que me anoté en una
escuela de programación un curso
completo y para mi sorpresa mis
compañeros de la nada que ver con lo que
yo me había imaginado yo pensé que voy a
encontrar con un arts gente con anteojos
gente de informática
nada que ver a mi izquierda tenía una
profesora de inglés de 60 años que
quería aprender a programar porque sus
alumnos estaban haciéndose plataformas
online a mi derecha tenía un médico
cirujano que quería desarrollar algo
para mejorar el sistema de salud en el
fondo de la clase un chico de 17 años
que todavía no terminó el secundario y
que no quiere seguir una carrera
universitaria formal lo interesante de
este entorno es que los profesores todos
son más jóvenes que yo
y no sé ustedes pero en el lugar donde
yo me eduqué siempre el profesor era el
que más sabía del tema y sin embargo acá
los alumnos corrigen adelante todo el
mundo al profesor cuando se equivocan y
frente a preguntas que el profesor no
tiene la respuesta dice no se preocupen
publiquemos los entonces abre la
computadora lo proyecta y empieza a
agobiar las preguntas porque les
comparto esto
es importante tener en cuenta que
existen muchos mitos respecto de la
capacidad de innovar y en realidad no
hace falta tener grandes ideas muchos
recursos estar en un laboratorio o ser
un científico lo que sí es muy
importante es investigar dediquen tiempo
a ver
que hay sobre el tema que están pensando
porque de hecho seguro seguro algún
chino ya se le ocurrió
ustedes tienen una red de contactos
enorme tienen amigos conocidos
familiares que seguramente les pueden
presentar a alguien que ya está
trabajando o tiene experiencia o
inclusive fracaso en lo que ustedes
están queriendo desarrollar aprovechen
eso junten se entrevistan a gente en
concreto lo único que necesitan para
innovar es una computadora
una libreta y un celular
nada más innovar es pura actitud muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]